okay hello everyone welcome to another
orphan language design review session
part of our language completeness and
consistency series
all right we supposedly have three
topics I bet they won't be simple
first one is about the where to store
things
interface okay
so there's
so there are four bullet four bullet
points here which
are all sort of uh bands around this
issue but you know they're distinct
points
um
yeah the the
um
so uh right so we have right so audio
has this you know choose where to store
the thing you know okay let's let's just
set the basic Point here basic point is
we've got a bunch of output forms
that
and they are all output forms I think
initially
that
might or might not actually store the
goods so to speak inside them
yep
and you know there are a bunch where I
could just copy it and paste it
somewhere and use it as input because it
has the goods inside it or that it has a
reference to the goods and other cases
where it's like sorry it's just a
picture
is that correct uh well I think
uh
well I think well I don't think audio
really falls into that category right I
mean it's never just a picture I don't
think
oh but but by that I mean okay so look
audio is a very bad case because okay
the issue is I mean the first three fall
into that category right that that thing
may or may not store the data whereas
audio always stores the data no it
doesn't sure
it specifically doesn't store the data
it has a pointer to a file that stores
the data well but yeah but it still
knows the name of that file right but it
never actually stores the data I can
never pick this up and copy it and paste
it into a new session well okay yes you
absolutely can no no I know that but but
this is the gotcha here I can't send it
to somebody else and have it ever work
well but you can you can choose to store
it in The Notebook
well no I can't yes yes there is the
Encore version for the audio object you
know see the little store icon
this one here yes
that we introduced only like three
months ago and you were very excited
about yes okay fine
does it have a mouse over yes it does
okay I guess I'm I mean so long as we
can teach people that that icon means
storage
okay so yes I I agree this is this is
this is really good store notebook store
in the cloud store in private cloud
right that's really good
right so right so one item I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna ask something
else why does this not have store as a
local object
because that is just a file which is
exactly what this already is no no I I
know that but but I might want it in my
just think about the following thing my
local Object Store might be something
accessible from multiple computers it
might be this that and the other this is
a queen if you decided that it's useful
we can add it easily
I think it's useful because I think it's
something we should standardize I think
we should standardize on this we should
standardize on what we're doing for all
of these because I think audio is rather
special in just having a randomly
scattered file be usable
right most of these other things don't
have that like for example here
um
right
you know here
well you need to write evaluate it in
this session right
let me let me do that okay
um
okay
so now this only offers me to store the
expression in the notebook it's not
offering me other alternatives
uh right it's a well yes I mean there's
the iconize option next to it but yes
can I argue why we might want these same
options for this as well does that make
sense
stored in the cloud doesn't seem
completely stupid to me
um
you know why is there go go ahead uh
uh
I would like Lou to opine I feel like
there was some issue with the fact uh
um but maybe not
um right there are large outputs
specifically or uniquely things that you
want to be able to store elsewhere
what I'm suggesting is that every large
thing
okay I have this option that allows you
to make it
okay
if it's in the notebook you can send the
notebook and you know it's all good
right
if it's not in the notebook
for whatever reason
you might want some way that you could
have Global access to it
John folks do you want to comment on
this
oh right so so I mean why don't you go
ahead and click on it right because this
is I feel like is a little bit different
from
the other guys just in terms of the
behavior and maybe this is purely a
historical accident right I know this is
what what why we're talking about it
here because I don't think it should be
different I think I think we need to
standardize how this works yeah let me
finish my sentence please Stephen yeah
please go ahead
right and so what did
um
right so if you click on that one and
and then embedded notebook
uh okay so it says embed in line in
Notebook is that what it says here
no it's got different wording come on
guys yeah the wording is different
because the operation is different right
that's why we're saying before uh that
output firm is a failure in the case of
sparse array but is a perfectly valid
one uh in in the audio case if you look
at the input firm of that audio is just
audio file the data there is the file uh
no it's not yeah
this is taking exactly
percent and sticking percent in there
which is uh quite different from what
the button in the audio where it's
taking exactly something which is not
percent and replacing
that output there I see is dramatically
changing the input form of the thing
well right but but I don't think the
wording is quite right because I think
store a notebook it should say embed
data directly in notebook or something
yeah that's fair okay yeah that's fine
okay
but I mean this word in here embed
inline and notebook is awfully similar
to you know this could say embed inline
and notebook can be reasonable couldn't
it
the problem is embed one right
um it is unclear because the audio
object is already correct and a valid
input firm it it as you said embed data
is a bit more explicit in what it would
do or maybe maybe import and embed
yeah something along those lines have
been doing is a bit awkward
you still haven't this
okay
um
hi Zoom is confused okay
um
well okay so there's there's wording
there but I just want to clarify there
are many different places here
where
it seems to me
maybe somebody can can correct this that
all of the storage locations make sense
probably
um I mean I think it's a I think the
case of the big you know the big output
it's it's not crazy to do as a matter of
fact it's very much not crazy I would
have I you know what now that I think
about it storing it in the cloud would
have been a big win would be a big win
for lots of things I'd want to do I
hadn't had that idea that one could do
that
but it would actually be useful to do
that
I guess the question was what would it
look like once you've done that
right it would have the same preview
that it's stored in here but its backing
would be the cloud that's certainly not
what we do in the in in the summary box
case right we indicate where it's stored
right so which case if I do this store
to the
let's say I do this now and I say store
oh this says store in local object okay
what the hell this this doesn't allow me
to do the public Cloud versus private
cloud
this is very confused guys because well
it's older right I mean we we didn't
so let's let's just pull this out yeah
okay
that's that one
you want to right click and show actual
side as well okay fine
okay that's oh shoot I I managed to
Mouse over that but
um
uh
um okay what other cases are there of
this of this menu
Is this different or is this the same
that one does not have
any options other than
right
Okay so we've got a big
this is a quintessential LCC problem
right because this store now does
something different from this store now
well not no no no no no yes it does look
at it
give us a menu okay fine but that that's
a trivial distinction I mean origin
originally and and I'm actually
suggesting we change the wording there
um right because it says data not a
notebook store now but two out of the
three or three out of the four if we add
if we split the cloud into two will not
actually store it in the notebook so we
should probably say something like data
not saved or data not stored yeah right
um okay I have a preference between
those two uh let's think about it let's
try and look at all the cases okay so
first point is
we're agreeing I think we have a lot of
uh sort of iconic forms
that
don't store the data right now we want
to get to the point where every iconic
form that doesn't actually have the data
stored has an option to store the data
do we agree
I'm sorry can you say that again I got a
loss in the sentence okay
what I'm saying is
we want it to be the case that every
everything where it's sort of an iconic
form
that doesn't that isn't okay
anything anything we want to make every
non-interpretable iconic form
interpretable
or have the option to have it be
interpretable yes okay I I don't think
that's an absolute rule because you know
of various data structures Etc but I
kind of agree with you yeah but as a
general principle yes okay and I think
also when it isn't interpretable I think
it should behave in a uniform way
yep
okay so okay so now let's discuss
basically what I would like to do is
let's enumerate all the cases where we
have these you know non-locally you know
not locally stored things question one
question two what are they what are they
presenting right now
and then idea you know then the concept
would be we'll take the best practices
of everything we see and make that the
standard so I mean unless you want to
include video which has no in Notebook
form
um I believe this is the complete list
okay so right of course there are 5 000
different things that use summary boxes
but they're all going through this this
centralized mechanism so sparse array is
a representative of what's another
example
what's that what's its interpolating
function another example uh yes
oh nice
and let me make the distinction once
again that we've already touched on
these are two there are two flavors of
this one is where the uh the output is
in non-valid and non-reconstructible
anymore in the other one the reserves
might not be accessible and these are I
think and in the second flavor is the
one that audio and video belong to
um I I don't think they're as different
as you think because imagine that I
stored my interpolating function in the
cloud
sure okay and then I can't access that
cloud file
I'm in the same now the only difference
with audio and video is that you think
things will be strewn around the file
system
yeah
okay now it is not self-evidently
obvious
that
you know I don't think it makes sense
for interpolation
and you know it's not self-evidently
obvious that sparse array a bile of you
know some sparse array format shouldn't
work
do you see what I'm saying yeah
and then it would be the same in the
same
you know bucket as the audio case
yeah no I feel like that is not because
if you generate if you regenerate your
own spice array as a result of
computation it'll be that
I understand that but I'm saying that
with audio if you generate your audio
okay right now as a an efficiency hack
even audio generated within the system
is outsourced to a file to be stored
correct
uh not in all cases it could be in in
the notebook because of these two
different modalities in core and out of
curl in The Inquirer all the data is the
input in the input form but what I'm
claiming is there's really no difference
between the case of you know if I said I
don't know what the sparse array formats
are there's a let me call it you know uh
sparse array a file of you know Matrix
dot you know sparse Matrix or whatever
it is I I don't remember what format
names are maybe somebody here I bet Rob
knows Rob here Rob knows the actual name
I don't even remember there's a DOT mat
format there's a no that's not sponsor
right yeah oh is this okay yeah well
it's from that Matrix Market thing I
think
um oh MMX Matrix mod whatever it is I
don't know I don't know what it is
I can't remember the extension for that
okay all right fine okay
all right fine I don't feel so bad now
that you didn't know that but that's
okay but we will get the point this
could be an external large file
right
does that make sense to people I mean
yeah but is that and how do you
envisioning that working like audio in
and out of code fashion or importing the
stuff and who knows who knows I mean
this is why I'm saying audio has an
immediate difference with stuff that
exists already
um this could work as in the same way
that there's no reason why it shouldn't
but I mean
Leonard's chunking you know out of court
chunking mechanism we could easily have
functions that take things like this
yeah it doesn't happen that the
implementation of sparse array is an
out-of-core implementation right now
yeah yeah no I I understand the only
difference is that the only claim that
I'm making is that the input firm for
one will be valid the other one won't
and and my claim is that there are right
dozens of summary boxes throughout the
system and some of them this file thing
will just not make sense unless yeah
fair enough fair enough I'm not pushing
it particularly hard I'm okay but I'm
going to push a different thing here
okay the the main thing that is weird
and perhaps wrong
okay about audio and video is that these
other things perfectly happily have
local object files
they don't
I'm sorry that is a possible option for
video no I I understand that I
understand that but what you're doing
if I just create okay let me let me do
something very straightforward here
because I'm I'm about to prove why this
is horrifying
okay
um
Hello computer are you hearing me
okay where is that file
okay that is just blamingly crazy
so we we have ways to control that right
I don't I I mean I disagree with that
assertion yeah it's blamingly crazy yes
I also don't think that is particularly
crazy okay I did send your documents the
right right you created a bio it goes
into your documents directory that is a
completely standard behavior of
applications although for us local
object the local Object Store is the
place we traditionally store and can
manage right because we can get a list
of local objects Etc et cetera you know
I may have accumulated all kinds of crud
in this and I know many applications do
this to to accumulate crud in the
documents directory well another thing
is actually at least on Mac OS now
certain directories like downloads and I
think documents when an application
accesses them from the first time a
dialogue comes up saying do you want to
allow it to access your whatever folder
and and for for one I mean that dialogue
is kind of annoying so maybe if it can
be avoided that would be good but also I
don't know what happens to this
functionality if they say no does it
just audio just kind of break if they
say no that might be the case
okay we should check that does anybody
does John or Lou or anybody know doesn't
that doesn't that revert to Temporary
directory I thought we had code in place
that if we can't access documents we go
to uh to Dollar temporary directory
um but I don't think that fallback is in
place for audio
um so that's probably wrong but right
but but the other
um
right I mean the flip side of that is if
you want to you know actually make use
of that MP3 or wave whatever type of
file it created there
um you know right you want to stick it
into your you know into your iMovie
project while documents is findable in
the finder whereas library is not
library is a 10 directory now
well that's a good question I mean this
is a
but I mean at the same time the same
could be said of images or something and
you know normally you expect you'll have
to export them yourself
right
and in this case why would you care
where this is
for what that's what I'm saying is that
maybe it's I mean that would that would
be the argument for putting in some like
local object store or something is to
say there's no reason a user should ever
have to look at the raw file so just put
it in some corner or where you know
they'll never see it I mean that's fair
and then you're expecting the user if
they want to use the outside assistant
do export of that audio object is what
you're saying yes which is perfectly
reasonable to me no maybe one other
concern though would be that uh you know
suppose the user has like 20 Gigabytes
of videos and audio in these folders
you know then that would be an argument
for them having you know making them
visible so that a user can clear them
out as opposed to being in some obscure
bizarre point maybe that forces us to
have a good management system for the
local Object Store which I wouldn't mind
seeing
maybe maybe that you know when we have
notifiers working
you know we could easily have a Notifier
that says you know where it says your
local Object Store now has 100 gigabytes
in it do you want to do something about
it
I mean we're going to have to manage the
stuff somehow because I have no idea
like my local Object Store I have no
idea how big it is
and
it will be good I feel like managing the
local Object Store is just as hopeless
as managing dollar documents directory
when you know every file name is a uuid
well okay but but my point once again
with finder you can at least do things
like right go in and I suppose we could
invent interfaces with uh for local
objects right but of course with well
why don't we just have it have you be
able to find it with a file right with a
file browser I could go in and you know
sort by date or whatever yes but why
don't we do that for the local Object
Store it's just a file system isn't it
just files it's nothing it's just files
it isn't no yes it is no it's a
directory every local object is a
directory with okay at least two files
okay well isn't that nice it probably
means that it's annotatable probably
means it has some metadata but in terms
of the just the pure how big is it and
what were the dates the directory will
do fine it'll sort just fine
and we could open a browser on the you
know one of the things you could do is
with I don't know we could we could have
some local object browse or something
function where you open a browser on the
local Object Store
which seems somewhat useful to me
I I think we should build management for
the local Object Store I mean unless
we're going to kill the local object
store and just spray files all over
people use the file systems I think we
should have a management system for the
local Object Store
the
um I've been wanting to have
um storage management for audio video
files that we create under this user
document directory because it's just
growing large but don't do it so that's
what I'm saying don't do it don't invent
another system I noticed that fnorp on a
live stream is commenting isn't it seems
a bit rude if the program silently
writes files to folders the user regards
is under that control like the documents
directory well yes I mean lots of
programs do it but yes it is kind of
rude
um
I I strongly favor centralizing all the
stuff in the local Object Store that was
what we built it for we can have
management system for it we should
figure out how to do that we should you
know we should share the management of
large objects that go there from you
know
you know let me clear about another
thing I mean where does it go in the
cloud by default does it go into a uuid
in the cloud I think it does doesn't it
the default cloud storage here
it just just the uuid and that's another
thing I noticed
um that might be we might be able to
improve just it it might be nice to have
them all grouped in one folder or
something
maybe I mean the alternative would be a
management system for local objects and
Cloud objects that allows you to do that
grouping dynamically
I mean the alternative okay based on
type and date and things like that
you're thinking for example but I mean
the alternative would be that everything
audio video well okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna make an argument that I'm gonna
shoot it down okay my argument would be
perhaps we want something where sparse
array big output
all have their own subdirectories in
wherever the storage bin is okay that's
my argument now my anti-argument is okay
are we going to have a separate one for
audio capture and for audio how do we
Bend these things I think it's hopeless
but so so then what we could do
is have something where in the metadata
it knows what function created it audio
capture versus audio versus whatever
else and then have a a management view
where you can see what were all the
creation functions for all the things
that wound up in the in the local Object
Store
or the cloud Object Store
so I'm not sure I totally understand the
distinction but I think there would be
value in having the actual you know
directory structure of the local store
you know have structure instead of just
being a bunch of uu IDs because
otherwise what I think is going to
happen is that people are going to say
or like this would happen to me as I
would say I'd scan my hard drive and say
this folder is using 100 gigabytes and I
just see a bunch of indistinguishable EU
IDs and I delete them all
when it might be better if I could see
oh well it's all the all my videos are
taking up all my space and I just delete
that folder and then I don't lose those
sparse arrays okay and stuff well
different okay so different programs
obviously have different conventions
about this some do things based on date
some do things based on uuid
I agree that having
sort of okay the real question is if
every local object is a directory that
means it has metadata in it in addition
to its content it has metadata
but the question is what Christopher is
asserting
is that
file system level visibility
of the types of things can be useful and
I don't disagree about that
okay however the alternative is that we
have a good enough management interface
that people won't go in raw and maybe
won't even be able to find the directory
you know it won't just go in raw I mean
if somebody sees it's the you know
wolfen language local Object Store oh I
found it on my hard drive it's big
you know maybe we should have a readme
write in that directory that says hey
you can go manage this directory by
using the local object store management
function
that would not seem to me stupid
to just to just say you're not really
this is not really a user this is not an
area I mean there's plenty of places you
know you can go to Dev Cayman or what is
devk mem called these days is it still
called that
I'm not sure what you're referring to oh
the kernel memory that's in the file
system
does it not hold that anymore it used to
be called slash Deb slash k-man back in
the day
um and you can you know you can go and
like start monkeying with that file but
that's your working memory for your
operating system kernel it's never going
to end well right but yeah yeah the the
that sort of thing is sort of not really
allowed anymore because you know
security
um yes well okay fair enough
you know I realize I'm on the losing
side here but I will make one one last
argument with in favor of documents
which is you know when you write
you know when your OS says you know
you're running low on disk here are some
places you might want to clean up I
think they probably look in documents
they don't look in library because
that's a hidden directory
I'm sure they look forward unless they
specifically look in caches which are
safe to delete this is I'm not sure any
OS I've never had a I mean maybe I I've
used Windows a long time maybe Windows
does that at least on Mac and Linux
though I don't I think usually they just
give you a dialogue that just sort of
says just delete some things and and
usually you're sort of left to using
your own programs and usually those
programs scan everything I thought they
had something that said that said you
know these files are using a lot of
memory I think I've seen that on on Mac
I know they have things like that for
for when you run out of ram it it starts
it brings up a dialogue to like you know
it says like pick a program to quit yeah
yeah um no I've seen it for disk as well
but it's available from the Apple menu
um okay but so is it does it look in
library or does it not look in library
um I bet it looks though
well we can determine the answer to that
that's something we should know
and
you know if it's I agree that if it's
deeply deeply deeply hidden we might
want to consider a different place for
the local Object Store too
I don't think so I really don't think so
okay that's a different issue I mean
and and and we should have management of
the local Object Store you know we
should have some way that you know I
don't know if you say you know about
in the about box or something we could
have something that says this is the
amount of space I know what anybody ever
looks there but we could at least have
something that says you know this is the
amount of space being used by the local
Object Store
doesn't wouldn't seem stupid to me to do
that
mm-hmm
um possibly useful as well for users to
specify how much they would like us to
use in their local stores exactly right
well um what happens when they you know
put something into a local I think that
exceeds that I mean how are you going to
enforce that in the need well I'll tell
you don't go manage right that that's
that's when we suggest go manage your
local objects
but it will bring up look with hoping to
have asynchronous notifiers be able to
come up in notebooks and it would say
you know with big flashing lights it
would say you know you you're you know
you're overrunning your local objects
store go manage it
okay
all right let's let's loop back here to
okay so it is my strong suggestion that
we take all audio and video and put it
in the local Object Store and never
spray files
well no we can't do that I mean I mean
if you're talking about auto-generated
files fine but right I mean
users will download their own audio that
they'll don't want to play sure they can
put wherever they want right then then
they're referring to it okay so
so let's consider release cases all
right
case number one
uh they recorded the audio with audio
capture or something or they
how do where where does audio come from
typically
let's say somebody's going to
I mean I think audio capture will be
fairly common but okay files are way
more common because audio capture
is doesn't have a super Advanced
accordingly interface okay so how do how
do you get a file you don't do an import
right because import would bring it into
you just type in file and then it'll
complete the path for you as you type
okay wherever you put it but import as
well import has the the mode that just
gives you the audio of a file name
rather than importing the data in
okay okay fine fine okay so then import
can take what that file name is and copy
it or something
I don't know exactly what it should do
to to the local Object Store
well maybe that's wrong
yeah that's silly okay but let's listen
the thing that I think is important is
you're using an audio file that is
somehow local okay to you know that's in
your document structure or whatever else
okay you don't know that it just looks
like oh it's the next you know it's a
file okay then you send the notebook to
your friend and they can't get the audio
and everybody's annoyed
so the thing I would suggest is that we
indicate that it is not
yeah I mean it's not a globally
accessible location somehow
you know it's it's neither if it's in
the notebook
see what I'm saying so there's two cases
something that it is not shareable
on this specific machine this is what I
was saying that we have two flavors of
things with the summary box and audio uh
one the issue is sharing and the other
one is reconstructing in general even on
your own machine okay fine
right you you quit you quit the front
end and then when you reopen your file
the next day it's like oh you the result
of your five hour computation is gone
because
you didn't uh you know store it or
whatever
right
okay
so
let's um okay right let's uh let's zoom
out for a second what we're trying to do
so we're trying to get wording as
uniform as possible
okay first of all we've got these menus
okay so basically the items and the
menus are embed in line and notebooks
store in local object
storing Cloud Print public storing Cloud
Print private yep
okay
um
now this phrase data not in Notebook
right that that needs to be changed
right yeah that needs to be changed data
not saved data not stored it's something
like that so let's think about this okay
and again I think the the two flavors
will reflect will be reflected in that
sentence
okay but how about data not permanently
saved
I mean it for audio that is not true
right the data is permanently saved
um yeah I mean I think we're only
talking about the summary box case right
okay yes yes for a second I mean the
I mean do you think it's enough to say
data not saved save now
I mean in other words the data is in the
kernel
it's just not saved anywhere correct
maybe the word is embed or something
the problem is it isn't embedded it
might be in the cloud
I guess maybe it's embedded in the cloud
right right origin right originally
right originally this wording made sense
because the only option was the first
one it wasn't in the notebook and you
could stick it in the notebook now that
we have three other options
okay let me let me take another case
okay you you've you've saved it but
you've saved it in a private Cloud
object
then you send this notebook to your
friend
they don't have access to the private
Cloud object they're toast
I mean I don't yeah so
um well how about we I mean one other
point is
um
you know data not persistent save now
store now
um
see I'm worried that people think that
within this session if we say data not
saved save now
that people will think even within this
session it isn't
I see
um
I mean we've got the whole notion of
persistent objects which is basically
what we're using here
is there any language we can get from
that
um
we we well we could I mean it's going to
be a bit verbose but we could do
something something like
um
data on my train of thought Earl sorry I
thought I had something
um but uh something something along the
lines of you know it's it's a session
local data only in session saved
permanently uh how about data not
permanently saved save now
uh I'm fine with that
permanently saved sounds a bit like if
you do permanently save it it's going to
be etched in stone yeah it does
I mean but but what is what's the
problem with just saved I mean
data not saved
yeah
right you have a Word document right
right especially since you're going to
say say there's a save now so clearly
it's still available it's just not I
think people understand the difference
between a say you know a saved file and
an unsaved file all right I got once uh
one visual suggestion how about we make
this italic
just a small visual suggestion because
it feels like it's it's a different kind
of communication than this one up here
well that's why it's a different color
and different font all right okay just a
suggestion I'm I might be wrong you do
have Jeremy and Billy here as well oh
well okay well they can have an opinion
about this they're probably not paying
you to pay attention I I was but you're
you were off screen well on my view
because I was 100 what were you pointing
to
I'm pointing to this this piece here
change that data not saved save now and
making that italic
I think italic will be fine which one's
not italic about which case
down here
um I think italic will be fine I'm not
sure what it means for this
maybe that should be italic as well
which actually would help me I would
like that because that it's confused me
that this is sort of like content and it
isn't content
um okay
how about when where when this data is
available like data only accessible and
this in this session kind of like we
have persistence language
rather than not a couple of people on
our live stream is suggesting the data
will expire when session ends persist
question mark
um
I would prefer a statement that session
data unsaved
I think that's hard to understand
I mean I think it's one of those things
where once you understand it you
understand it but you don't understand
it when you first see it
um
okay Harry is making an interesting
comment here about
um
a notebook level dialogue that says is
there anything in this notebook
or some other indicator I mean so
there's a separate project about that
and I don't want to get sidetracked by
that right now okay but I'm just going
to make a great Point as we've only
gotten through the one of the four
bullet points okay okay fine fine but I
mean I'm just gonna make the point that
that might suggest that we might want
some kind of footer information here
about there being unsaved things in the
I mean just like we have the the bit up
here that shows that there's stuff that
isn't saved you know that there's that
the actual notebook content isn't saved
there could be a thing and that's a John
question how that might work you know
maybe we want something over here that's
some kind of you know flash you know
little thing that looks like one of
those you know notebook is dirty type
type indicators
so parth has been working on uh a more
General concept of a uh per notebook
notification system
um
and I think this potentially fits with I
mean when would the notify come up
I'm sorry when would the notify come up
when you press save
well I mean there would be some
that's part of what he's figuring out
but there would be you know some you
know I mean like operating system level
notifications you know there would be
some weak sort of notification that's
like you know hey a thing happen now I'm
gonna go hide myself uh but I'll leave a
little you know I don't see the trigger
I don't see the trigger unless it's on
Save
see what I'm saying I mean you could
trigger on save every time you press
save there could be a little Notifier
that comes up saying this has unsaved
things well I mean I I mean the trigger
can be the just the production of the
thing in the notebook it's I mean it's
not about whether or not it's saved it's
about whether or not the the data's in
the notebook right I'm a web but it's
already telling you it's not in the
notebook when you produce it
yes but you have to be looking at that
spot on the screen you might it could
have been produced inside of a closed
cell group it could have been produced I
agree notebook that it's a mile high my
suggestion is number one it could notify
and save a number two that we consider
some little piece of iconography that
indicates they're unsaved things in The
Notebook
my suggestion we can let's move on from
there
can you communicate that at least as a
suggestion
yeah yeah I mean I mean my my one
reservation is I I just I don't want to
have you know you know for us to grow 10
different types of notifications for 10
different types of events I'd like to
completely agree I'm just I'm just
saying I think this is an untriggerable
notification there are plenty of
notifications that are triggerable where
I 100 agree it's going to be a little
Notifier in the corner of the screen and
that's all there is okay um okay
um
the um
okay so okay so that's that part so
we've got I think we should try data not
saved save save now as the
um
yeah that's fine
okay
then we've got a a menu there
yeah and we'll need to add one Cloud
item yes
then better in line and not because it
seems a fairly non-stupid thing to say
as one of the the save items I like that
um
okay that looks good okay let's look at
audio now
Okay so
where's the data not saved in oh God we
have no indication of that because it is
saved I know so why don't we say and so
that's where where
um
before we dig into this maybe you should
look at the because they're working on
an audio redesign so maybe you should
click on The Links at the top
uh that take you to
[Music]
okay
is that the one
yep
okay so what am I looking at here
here right that's the top part is
unification or making it more similar to
the video GUI but the bottom part
is an effort to unify these storage
problem
right and so you see how it's sort of
very explicitly States what sort of data
is backing it
um
I mean I'm I'm thinking about
this iconography
it's kind of silly where if it's in a
cloud object already it's like oh you're
going to save it somewhere else as well
you might want it within the notebook if
you're sharing it with someone with no
internet access or something like that
or you just feel like it's well and what
are you going to do in this case here
where it's okay so we've got to discuss
this in this case here where it is in
the cloud what does it say when this is
in the cloud it says that it's stored in
the cloud
so you can go ahead and click on it and
see what happens yeah
and here if I say storing Cloud yep
sending all kinds of crud to the cloud
and what what are the permissions
default permissions for this public in
that case and there's a private Cloud
case and that's the that's the different
case that we want are you sure that is
by default in the public one I am Lou
well okay I don't I don't know I don't
think so and this is why the public one
in in the audio one
was again for the same user to make this
available in different sessions instead
the audio for audio the motivator is be
able to share with others so I think
this should be changed to follow exactly
the wording here data stored in
Cloud just Cloud paren public data
stored in Cloud brand private
that's what I think
and if you want more information like
where was it actually stored there
should be some click array clickeroo
here where you can get the information
on where it's actually stored absolutely
I believe I believe that is exactly what
you do
um okay well I mean okay so but there's
got to be a ux indication there that you
can get that this is copy to cut board
fine that's a reasonable way to get it
out the public private could be easily
confused with permissions I'm worried
about that
it is permissions it's not private Cloud
versus no public cloud with private
permissions no okay the dotted line
looks like the private Cloud logo oh I
think that comes from a misunderstanding
between Billy and me then okay because I
was talking about uh
and evidently Billy had uh uh
misunderstanding let's fix it I I agree
a lock icon would be great there okay
fine okay okay
what about the local object case
you
said you said no no you said that we
shouldn't say cloud object we should
just say cloud
we can't do that in the local objects
well you could say stored in local
object
rather than I'm just saying don't use
the actual you know symbol name thing
well we could do that I don't know it's
it's okay except that I'm worried about
the fact this public goes private I'm
also concerned well what about when we
say private Cloud object or you know
just add the
public and private either as a
parenthetical or as a adjective in front
of cloud objective we shouldn't add it
as an adjective in front of a kennel
case camels don't like adjectives
at least that's my theory
um
but
uh
let me see the um
was it gonna say I am a little worried
about private clouds and other
permissions you know structures
and I'm wondering if there should be a a
look I think there should be a thing
down to more than one Cloud at a time
and you can just go through whatever
yes but here's what I think we should do
I think we should have some Escape valve
here where you can just say where you
want it stored
but you can type a file name you can
type a cloud name all those kinds of
things we can just type a URL a URI
basically where you want things stored
thank you
know just to select
or something to decide where to store it
you know probably not used very often
but from time to time will be very
useful because you don't want to have to
that that way you can I mean honestly at
that point what is the advantage over
export file name comma percent just
cleanliness on the notebook which I've
certainly wanted many times
it's cleaner in the notebook it's nice
to be able to have something in the
notebook just points off to where you
want it to point
let's try and get ux for that okay and
let's go look over here and
and by the way we we don't support
uh in for front-end operations we don't
support multiple simultaneous Cloud
connections
yet right well it's yet is true but it's
also true that I I mean there's so much
work behind it and the motivation yeah
the prioritization of that work is
unclear
yeah not necessary right now
okay so
um
I think this is very unclear having this
here
and um
well
I I wouldn't say integer 16 that's a
micro oh yeah I'm sure that can be just
don't know that we don't need
so you're saying just have data and
Notebook full stop yeah okay
I mean it was a way to try to get a
little bit more distinguishability
without
having the whole picture there
um
I'm still concerned about this
that it's completely unclear what that's
about
I mean really what this is is change
location
right and so the tote right which uh
right it has a chrome it says change
storage location amazing yeah
I mean it feels like this should just be
uniform with this other stuff data
stored in Cloud
paren public data stored in Cloud
here
data stored in local object
now the one case that's special
you know
data stored in Notebook okay those are
all exactly the same the one case that's
that's special is the random file
in which way because why not just say
data in colon and then the name of the
file
or just file colog and then the name of
the file
that's my suggestion
that makes sense how would that be
different than just file Dot and file
name
I'm just saying to make it uniform in
terms of of the the thing with with
saying data stored in Notebook right you
just say
it's like saying just file colon and
then the name of the file
I just think it's more human readable
than the other case
okay so so what are we showing in the
cloud object case now you now you've
lost me so in the cloud object case what
are you today
um
data
well whatever what do we say here we say
data data stored in Cloud I think is
what we should say
something like that
or possibly we can allide that to say
what I was going to ask
if it's too short we'll just say data in
Cloud whoops
or stored in Cloud what do you prefer
I think this shoulder the better just to
make it fit in the smallest amount of
possible space well do you like data in
cloud or stored in Cloud I think dating
cloud is my vote but fine sounds fine to
me
so the the uh counter argument to this
and for the current design proposal was
that uh this allows you to get to
differentiate as ETA was saying between
uh audio objects if they are backed by
different Cloud objects you get at least
a snippet of the name of the cloud
object so you you'll be able to tell
uh that is the advantage of good luck
yeah
that's that's where I don't mind this
way to figure that out anyways so well I
mean you could argue that for these
other things as well the reason we're
not arguing that for these other things
is because every one of these other
things has some information about what
it is yeah
now I mean
let me follow your argument for a second
okay I've got two sparse arrays each of
size a million right the factors they're
different and they are stored at
different uuids
but I cannot see that without seeing the
uuid
do I care
that's fair and hovering over the
whatever text will be will give you a
preview of the waveform and yeah okay
but I mean maybe I do care maybe it is
worth seeing a piece of the uuid what do
other people think
anybody comments
right I like the idea of seeing at least
part of the uuid
um you know
uh and all right with high probability I
could you know I could at least tell if
they're the same or not
right I might not well then maybe we
should put the uuid here piece of the
uuid here and then we can put in parens
public
and if we need to align we could just
say data in Cloud object yeah blah blah
blah
okay and then paren public and then here
we'd say data in Cloud object blah blah
blah run public
I think we can just say file colon
because I think it's obvious that that's
a stored in and I think it's worthwhile
to give a bigger part of the file name
there
does that make sense does that make
sense
yep
okay anything else we need to figure out
here uh there are two things
um one is uh
some things about camels
titles well yes there's one thing about
but let's do with the simpler one which
was the font right so when you first
evaluated Big Data equals blah right the
font was Gray
and you asked in some meaning which
didn't involve any of the people who are
relevant uh why is it gray and well the
short answer is because you said so but
the slightly longer answer is because
it's not interpretable so when you
evaluate the those first two inputs
you'll see that the font of the output
size limiter is gray and the font of the
head of the sparse array is gray and
then once you store the data somewhere
those two fonts turn black
but it doesn't look great to me what's
gray where's where's something gray
uh well the the font of the text uh here
one two three four five yes maybe you're
not calling that gray but uh I guess the
it was not black and you asked wow
cool asaurus
I mean I didn't yeah I mean we were
being very clever
yeah perhaps too clever
right and the same thing would happen
with sparse array so you see right now
the head is
is black but when he first evaluated it
it oh that's really subtle
look my suggestion except since version
nine right we've used the color of the
head to indicate whether it's
interpretable or not
right I mean it's something we've done
consistently no no it's fine I'm not I'm
not making a big fuss about that I'm
just
I think I was just frustrated because I
found it hard to read one of these some
one of these big you know because we've
gone to smaller font is it a gray font
here as well as being gray background
yeah it's not black it's dark you know
dark gray
there's also a gray dotted outline
that becomes solid
I would suggest just going a little bit
lighter in the background a little bit
darker with the fonts and then
everybody's going to be happy
I just I just want to make it not
unreadable you know because I I had a
case where I just really just couldn't
really read it okay
um okay that was that now we've got some
casing right and I think we're mostly
okay so all of these you know sort of
store now simple interfaces yeah
um then you know menus and context menus
use title case yep the one problem case
I found was the was the image editor
toolbar uh
um
which
part of that right which I would
recommend we'll just look at it and fix
it but itai suggests that maybe we can
come up with some rules
right for for example why is that more
dot dot lowercase
well
um the last app
I don't mind I like that one being low
lower case yes
that's an icon not text
let's see right so buttons they all used
title case except for two that I found
um
I think action buttons should use title
case I think things that
are more commentary oriented should use
initial caps
and then titles like as you flip through
those
um those tabs I think titles of those
sections as well camel cased
or title case title case yes I think
that's reasonable
right that's reasonable yes although uh
yes the the one uh the one interesting
inconsistency I found there is that the
the tool tip for the more is you know
initial case more tools and actions and
the actual title once you click on it is
Capital actions and tools
um I don't think that's too horrifying
well it's more horrifying is there's an
extra space before the Amazon yep
horrifying and and yes and then once you
click on it you'll see that there are
some things with no why am I seeing why
is this being obstructed at the top
what's happening oh that
seems like a bug yeah there's something
wrong there
yeah
this doesn't bother me much that the the
mouse over is a slightly different
Capital right right and and then I'm
just pointing that all of these entries
here are all lowercase which
maybe they should be I'm just they look
fine I mean I think they honestly I
think this looks fine okay
all right let's just try and hit one
more thing and then is this easy
I think it's easy but I am out of here
in 10 minutes one way or the other stuff
in here so
uh
uh so uh the issue is that we want to
have a minor feature extension to item
uh where item can take a margins option
and this would be entirely equivalent to
embedding a pane with the with the same
margins inside the item and and with
alignments you know uh sensible to me I
think is a good is a good holder for
things like that yeah and this was a
thing that Carlson had asked for to
simplify the Box structure for data set
for example so I like it
now the question is what to name the
option we've often used frame margins
for this sort of thing but but this
isn't quite a frame if we called it
frame margins you might think that like
in a in a grid box that it would
stretches all the way to the edge of the
frame but item margins uh and so item
margins was so that's the thing right
yes
and if you're happy with the name item
margins I mean I'm I'm just that
manipulate is just illustrating how
spacings and this proposed thing are
really I think it's useful very
different animals
um you know spacings or spacings around
dividers they're not margins on
individual items
why you'll note that when you change the
spacings it changes symmetrically
um
it's really a divider spacing it's not
like you know margins for you know a
rower column or something like that
this is the margins of the item this is
the spacing of the between the rows okay
and you could do item spacings on the
whole grid
or can you
um so spacings is a grid level option
nothing is changing there I'm just gonna
Jeremy is asking item margins at the at
the top level and have it um yeah
percolate down and the answer should be
yes
um
so that's I mean it's a thing that we
could do uh but to be clear if you know
if we did it would act in this way which
is to say it would add to spacings
that's fine
there's no other way to Puff out every I
like the idea of having this I mean we
we have size don't we have an item size
option we do have an item size option
yes right so there's two different
things there's the puff out which is the
margins and then the item size which is
the locking the whole thing and in terms
of size yeah yeah what's the interaction
is this is the item size then tied
around the five
or uh
the uh well right in in this example the
item size is automatic
um right but if we were to set an item
size what
yeah I believe it is uh so your question
is essentially does item sizing uh uh
Does it include spacings or exclude
spacings like think it excludes spacings
but honestly I don't remember 100 for
certain but I mean the item size will be
the literal size of this box in the in
the grid right if I say exercise is
whatever right so then then the only
question is if there are item margins
there and you specify great big item
margins but the item size is too small
what happens
uh then uh then it gets squeezed in
until it just doesn't uh the item size
has has Primacy I think yo the question
is the the item content here does it
still try to maintain the item margins
thereby crushing the inner content yes
yes if if you specified a margin greater
than the size
um or greater than half the size because
it's coming in from multiple directions
then you'd end up with a thing that
looks empty
so it's kind of lower priority the
actual content in the middle is lower
priority than the margins
yeah
it's not obviously correct but
it is it it is how I mean what I'm
describing is how pain works
uh so
it seems it seems reasonable to me this
item margins idea seems reasonable to me
um should we have the default setting
there is it default zero or is there
some other value
the default would be zero yes
because what we're seeing here is not
very nice the left and right that
crashes into the edge which happens by
default that's that's not nice at all
well it's like plot margins what's the
default value of plot margins it's not
zero is it
uh uh the plot margins there there isn't
the plot margins
what do you mean there isn't the plot
margins plot do you mean plot range
padding oh yeah plot range party
yeah okay that's which is a different
concept okay so this plot range padding
how does that relate to a possible I
mean okay right because plot range
padding is really talking about the
range right it looks at the numbers that
are deranged and they add some fraction
to that or possibly a fixed number but
typically it's a fraction of of that
okay so so if you want to see the
current interaction which maybe isn't
entirely correct of uh in pain of frame
margins and uh image size I just put an
example in chat
and this this not exactly obey what I
said and I'm not sure that I'm sure that
this is correct
um the uh that so so the ABC
disappearing I would defend but then the
thing getting larger
I'm not sure I would defend I I I think
image size should probably take
precedence an exercise it should never
violate image size yeah
but aside from the changing image size
this is the behavior that I would
propose and
it would be consistent for all boxes
that have you know these kinds of option
settings
you know one thing we still need to work
on is all the graphics grid you know all
the padding and Graphics grids and so on
Brett isn't here is here
no I am oh you are okay
by the way I you know the bug some
random bug with plot labels in graphics
grids which is still not fixed
okay been there for many years I need to
get fixed okay but but you know what
I've wanted to do and maybe this we
can't do this right now obviously
I think we need some kind of summit
about padding in all things whether it's
in graphics Grid in you know plot with
axes whether it's in each of these
things because Jeremy is also commenting
here that grid with no padding isn't
very pretty
but the image margins Arrow zero
if that's the default isn't very pretty
oh well it's spacings it's the spacings
that I overrode it it is spacings is not
Zero by default
but somehow this crushes into I mean
this because it's the latest you know
option on the Block this one seems to
get precedence which is not obviously
correct no no no no no no
spacings what I'm saying is spacing is
an item margins add together
it which is why I'm I'm trying to make
that clear in the in the in the
manipulate by coloring the pain box uh
okay uh with gray you know why is this
thing crashing into the left
because I set spacings look at the
spacings option
um yeah in the input
um
yes okay oh I see yeah because because I
explicitly set it to zero if you'd see
if it was automatic it wouldn't crash I
just set it to zero for illustrative
purposes
okay
I need to go you need to go I think come
we need to wrap up here one minute to
spare John yeah oh yes that makes me
happy okay
um we'll have to deal with the round and
then next time yep um
sounds good okay okay thanks a lot guys
see you all soon